Look at that! Yeah...
Did you know - candle
flames conduct electricity better than air.
That is because there are ions in the flame,
positively and negatively charged particles
resulting from the combustion process.
It's kind of a plasma.
And you can see that the
flame has two separate pieces two it now.
One is going towards the negative plate,
those would be the positive ions.
And the negative ions would be going
toward the positively charged plate.
These two plates are charged up to
20,000 volts, which in air can make a 2 cm spark.
But through the candle flame, it can make
a much larger spark because of those ions.
There are even ions in the smoke, which is why
it separates into two streams. The positive
charges go to the negative plate and the
negative charges to the positive plate.